[Music]
how's it going guys welcome back to demo
rpg we're up to episode nine and today
we're just gonna be working on an
equipment class and getting some uh
armor and weapons ready for characters
to equip now uh we had a lot of work to
do so let's get right into it first
thing we're going to do is just add a
new class or well in our case a new
header since we're kind of building a i
guess what's gearing towards a header
only library so let's just make a new
header called equipment and put it right
in along with everything uh now we're
this is we gotta think about this a
little bit first of all
uh how are we gonna do this you know we
need to think about that now luckily for
you i've thought about this ahead of
time for the most part so uh we're just
i'm just going to show you how to code
it all up i'm going to first give you a
little bit of the theory and then you're
going to code it all up okay so uh you
know rpg armor equipment system there's
a million different ways to do it every
game has their own little motif of what
they do and what they follow uh and
we're going to follow some of those but
we're also going to kind of come up with
our own so we're going to have an
equipment class
that we use to inherit from and that
equipment can be many different types of
equipment it can be armor or weapons for
the most part and we're going to call
armor as a chess piece headpiece etc
also we're going to put like rings and
amulets and things like that in there as
well so we just need to build
uh equipment and then the armor that
inherits from it and then weapons and we
also want to have slots because we want
to know what slots these items are for
and where you can put them you don't
want to be able to put a
sword on your leg well i guess when the
sheath is there but you get the point
you don't equip it there yeah it's a
a hand item you know you just want to be
able to make that all make sense so how
are we going to do it all right well
let's keep it as simple as possible
let's make a struct actually let's do
class called equipment
all right and let's just get this worked
out we don't want to be able to
instantiate this
so public private
um if we don't want anybody to
instantiate this the easiest way to do
it is to just make it and overload a
function well
later we overloaded and for this one
we're going to make a git type get
uh
equipment type where we'll just call it
get type and it's going to equal zero so
your virtual function you cannot
instantiate equipment anymore that's
going to be the whole point of this and
later we'll overload this just to say
what type it is whether it's a weapon or
armor because they're gonna they're
gonna be different and you're often
going to want to know because you could
have just a bunch of equipment slot
pointers and use a
polymorphism to make that equipment
either weapons or armor so that's going
to be kind of a useful function now
there's more we could do like we could
delete constructors and stuff
but
we're just going to stick with this
simple method of leaving a pure virtual
function here so that way you can't
instantiate equipment unless you're
creating a
equipment pointer and then later calling
it arm or something all right so what's
some of the basics we're going to need
here um basically we're going to need a
name right equipment's going to need
some kind of uh name we'll just use
string for this here we'll just call it
name so we're going to naturally need to
include string so it knows what that is
pretty straightforward there and as you
can see we have that private so it's
we're gonna need getters and setters and
uh let's see what else we're gonna need
what does equipment have what is it
gonna do and for the most part it's
gonna affect your stats
mainly
armor and resistance but well you know
it's an rpg okay we can have magical
items for special items so we also want
them to give you
some of your stats like strength
intellect agility maybe even hp is an mp
as well but we'll cross that bridge a
little later for now we're just going to
stick with stats so we're going to put
in core stats
and we'll just have stats
so the equipment's going to have stats
um
yeah so later we might have items too
that are different but for now we're
going to stick with just uh creating
this now it doesn't know what score core
stats are because we have to include it
core stats class that we've built and
we'll just pop back and look at core
stats this is what we worked on last
episode with all these overloaded
operators and stuff so that's handy
all right there we go very nice
and so we're gonna need some more stuff
in here uh like we're gonna need ways to
get and set this and the easiest way to
properly do it is with constructor and
uh that's what we're gonna stick with
however
we might as well just make it protected
since it's gonna be something you need
to inherit from anyway
and
we can use this constructor
that has it all built ready to go
standard string
uh we'll just do lowercase name here and
we'll say you've got to pass it in some
core stats here
we'll call it c stat
c stats
sounds like a medical term and we'll
just uh
use this little
way of doing it here where it just
creates with these directly and there we
go
we now essentially oh we need this to be
c stats so we have something that we can
inherit from and give a name and stats
and now let's go ahead and make the next
part now we got to think about this
we need some way to do slots and it
needs to be somewhat uh
somewhat exposed so
we're going to make a class for armor
slot we're going to work on armor first
so armor slot um
what different slots can you have let's
just uh stick with some basic seal here
and uh you know there's a lot of
different slots so we can uh we can pull
up google and go look at medieval
stuff
let me just paste this in here
and we'll see
we have all this
so there's some some basics to get you
started and here's some more ideas and
you can play other games to get ideas
but
ultimately you got to make some
decisions about how much of this you
want to do and how much you want to call
it now these all have a gothic
this is gothic plate armor with elements
and you can see a lot of stuff has well
names that i don't recognize too well
because i don't study that even though i
do like the stuff
but we don't want to use all of those we
just maybe want to keep it simple and
have a few slots this is definitely
something you can expand on later if you
want to add more other slots but for now
we're just going to use helmet uh chest
and
legs
and boots uh i guess we could have more
let's let's go ahead and add
uh ring one ring two
and nick those are pretty standard
and uh yeah it's an e-no so these are
all just numbers essentially but if you
create an armor slot variable it can
only be one of these at a time
and you know that's that's a good
portion of the stuff but maybe we also
want a few others like she and let's see
what else
uh probably want some kind of gloves so
let's put that over here after boots
gloves
hands or whatever you want to call it
i'm just gonna stick with the name
gloves
okay so there we go we got some basic
items now it's going to default to
helmet if you don't give it anything so
we could give it an undef
uh first one if they haven't defined
what it is but
um let's just uh let's just leave that
off we don't really need it in our case
sometimes we want to have a
not set or not defined
slot there or a name for your enum
but uh
we're just going to leave helmet as 0
slot 0.
all right so let's make a class that
inherits from uh equipment so we go
class equipment
or not equipment but
class armor
and it's gonna compare it from equipment
bring in
all the stuff but mainly we just want to
use this constructor we want to overload
this get type and visual studio has a
little feature where if you right click
on your new class and go implement all
pure virtuals it should work but it
doesn't work for this header only method
uh because so we're gonna have to just
type it in here uh hit type
now we're gonna do git type a little
differently than we were before before
we were like manually typing in like uh
return
armor right
but we can use some features of cpu plus
at least on a visual studio might be a
little different on linux or different
os's but you can use type id and then
you can uh
in parentheses put put the class or
struct and for this one since it's
inside this class we can just put star
this and that'll be a reference to this
armor class and then we want dot name
now this is uh
and gonna basically return
type info must be included before type
id is used okay very good so
we need to include type info
type info okay and now let's say you
let's just use this now what type id
returns is going to be class and armor
so it's going to return basically
uh const care of class armor as you know
it'll look like
look like this when it returns but we
can use that for displaying stuff or
checking what it is
um
later and we might pretty apply this a
little bit because we don't necessarily
want to say class armor but that that's
that's fine and if this was struck it
would say struck armor so you'll see
that here in a second as we start
building this up a little further and in
the end kind of make some tests in our
main to see that all this equipment
works so what do we need to do with
armor well this uh should be public
and we should probably also put over
right here it's actually optional
override there we go
and basically we need a slot so let's go
ahead and do that uh let's just keep
this public for now oops i accidentally
hit build actually it's uh there we go
that's fine
so slot uh and we'll just call this slot
right and then we're going to need what
else are we going to need we need you're
going to need a constructor now we don't
want anybody to default construct this i
don't think if they construct these they
they got to at least give it a slot and
they got to fill out this stuff here
so let's just defeat delete some of the
constructors here that we know we won't
use so let's just go
or we can just make it private however
you want to do it there's a couple
different ways of getting rid of the
base constructor one of one of the ways
you can do it is you can just make it
private you just go like this and
oh i guess we gotta give it a little
definition now it's a
private definition it seems to be
complaining about something it's got
some overloads it says
uh
no default constructor it doesn't let
you use this because you don't have a
default one for equipment uh so we can
do that too let me just go private uh
actually watch this it's not gonna like
this private one and you'll see why here
in a second it's because
this doesn't have access to to private
um
something that's inheriting only has
access to protected and public all the
private ones and it doesn't have access
to but we're going to just move that
down there there we go
and
so it's still going to complain it's
going to say it's inaccessible so it
does help you a lot here
uh so what do we do in that case well
now we can just not worry about it you
know we can just we can just delete this
and we could publicly say
armor equals delete this is just a
little
fast way of saying
it's probably correctly that you cannot
use
just a default armor if you create an
armor you've got to create it in a way
that has a legal constructor
so we'll get more on that later
because we can also say no copying is
allowed by going something like this
armor
fonts armor by reference
equals delete
and that'll say
no copying because this is a copy
constructor that means you can't make a
new armor and give it some other armor
type to break from and we can also
delete
uh const armor
double reference here to say
no moving there's no
moving another armor object into this
one so that just gets rid of some of
those uh base cases now is this correct
no that's fine so
that gets rid of most the ways you could
create armor but we need a legal one and
of course we're going to want it to take
a name stats and slot
and that's going to be mainly it so
how do we do that well
pretty easily i guess
basically we just do what we've been
doing in the in the past and if you know
already awesome but mainly we're going
to need this
this stuff name stats so we can just
take what's right here
paste it in here and we also want this
armor slot because you got to know what
slot it is
and we'll just call it slot lower case
and make this one capitalized
all right and also another thing we're
going to do with armor here is we're
just going to make it final and what
final does it says no one else can
inherit from armor it's the final
version of the class
it's possible we might want to change
that later but for now we just want to
make sure no one else is is going to
be making if you want a special armor
you just have to design this with a
different stats and stuff
now this sort of ensures that people
don't turn your classes into further
inheritance it's just not designed for
further inheritance so that's all it
really does
uh okay we're still working on this here
so we want to instantiate these now we
can just say we could just use this
constructor and go equipment with name
and c stats and that
is going to forward to this constructor
right here and end up setting right
there but slot well you probably know
how to do this one comma and then
slot these double brackets here but
there's nothing actually in here it just
uh constructs all this stuff directly
and there we go we have enough to make
the call this now how do we want to do
this slot
uh we probably want it private or do we
want people to access it now the thing
is if you leave it just publicly
accessible anyone can change it at any
time now if you design something that's
a chess piece we don't want some end
user just deciding it's now a helmet so
we probably want to make this private
because that makes sense and then we
will want some some getters and setters
and same with this you don't really want
anybody changing the name you don't you
don't want anybody just changing the
stats but
maybe you do it depends on your game but
in our case we're leaving these these
private because we don't want people
just changing them but also this means
when they're hidden like this you can't
just get to them so we need getters and
setters which can be a bit annoying to
make a bunch of but hey it's not that
big of a deal really so let's return a
string let's just do a get name kind of
like we did before that just returns
and we'll do the same thing for stats
hit stats
and it's just going to return stats
oh it's uh we need to return core stats
here
now this might be a bit overworked and
in reality maybe you know it like we did
some so we did these buffs as just a
struct so anyone can access all this
stuff just freely which is going to be
kind of nice for external design if
we're not worried about it now that most
of this private stuff in general is more
for like when you're messing with actual
internal stuff that cannot be changed or
it's going to bug stuff out like if
someone sets a point or wrong or someone
i don't know changes something that's
involved in networking or computer
memory or graphics and it just like
whatever it's using whatever driver or
hardware it's using on your computer if
it sets that stuff around wrong it's
gonna crash
that's typically the stuff you want to
be private all right so with that in
mind
let's just make it public all right that
way you know if people change these it's
not going to crash our program so
sure we might not want them to change
them but it's not actually that critical
is the point and maybe you see the point
there of you want to hide the more
critical stuff that's actually going to
cause serious crashes and bugs in
general now that's just sort of my take
on it other people might have different
opinions maybe people always want to get
her and setter but no matter what you
set these two it's not going to ruin our
program so if you want if you want a
piece of equipment that has ridiculous
stats in a ridiculous name then okay so
be it it's your your program it doesn't
matter to me or anybody or your computer
your computer's gonna be fine with it
too so it's you know it's not gonna
break its uh anything else but later
when we start designing stuff that talks
back and forth to the hardware we've got
to be a lot more careful about how we do
this kind of stuff and uh
yeah so that's that's why we're just
gonna make them public and say forget
about it and we can do the same with
slot so we'll just put these at the top
for now i like them being at the top
because you can just see what you're
working with and maybe we'll put all
these uh
unused functions at the bottom order
does not matter just whatever whatever
one of these it's under is what matters
so
now once you're in a class it just knows
about everything in its class so we got
the constructor can use we got get type
and we got about everything else now um
yeah so this worked pretty well and we
can assume it's
the the armor is going to give you the
stats now if we go look at stats uh in
its default construct
which we might end up using
it does something that we don't really
intend so let's just go look at our stat
block here and uh or rather our core
stats
and we see that sets strength agility
and intellect
to one by default now we don't want this
anymore because we don't want every
piece of armor giving you one strength
and agility just by default well it
gives it zero by default it's got to be
like magical or something so this might
break a few things with our character
and how we use core stats because
typically we want them to start off with
one but i think we have most of that
sorted out and if it comes up we will
address it but so yeah we're just going
to make that little adjustment on core
stats of just those defaulting to zeros
so there you go
and uh
yeah so you might know that a struct
everything's public by default so that's
why we don't have to type public above
all these but in a class everything's
private by default so in reality maybe
we should just be using structs here but
we've already typed class and it's fine
it's really fine either way you just got
to know that what it defaults to is
different
all right so armor looks pretty good
there let's think about weapons weapons
are going to be somewhat similar except
they're not going to take an armor slot
they're going to take a weapon slot so
we need to design a weapon slot and
other than that they're going to be
basically equipment with a name
and stats but also they need to do some
damage so we need to keep track of
damage but that's that's pretty easy we
can just compose that all in the class
so let's make another enum
class
weapon slot here
and it's going to take something like
well what are the different types of
weapons we have one handers we got two
handers and uh we got range so and we'll
keep it that simple all right so we'll
have a
melee
one-hander and we're gonna have a melee
two-hander and we'll have a ranged uh
slot and that that'll be good enough and
we'll use those so we'll just do
basically what we did with arm here
we'll go class uh except this one will
be weapon i'll also make it vinyl so no
one else
here from it and also it is equipment as
well and public we're going to have
a weapon slot and then we'll kind of
yeah we'll call it same thing slot
and we're going to basically do the same
thing we'll have this constructor
except ours is of course going to be
called
weapon
and it's going to take the same things
it's going to have this name and core
stats
and slot i guess we want all of this
we'll just rename that slot here in a
second i'll copy paste action to save
some time oh where did slot go there
okay
i must hit the wrong key there all right
here we go just paste that in there and
change this to weapon slot
and we're essentially going to do the
same thing here
so we can just copy this make sure we
get this
eye in there and uh slots gonna be slot
it's already this new type so
just the same name but uh that's that's
fine and we want to also make this
function and put it in here as well and
this should get class weapon on return
with this name here
and we can delete these constructors say
hey no copying or moving weapons or any
of that stuff and that's easy enough we
can just
just paste over all these
and uh you know this part is somewhat
optional
but
we might as well do it all right so
there we go now we have weapons and
armor somewhat ready to go we got base
class for them i think eventually we're
also going to go something like this uh
public items and items are probably
going to have like weight quantity maybe
or something like that but we'll cross
that bridge when it comes we're going to
stick with working on equipment for now
we don't have consumables yet but
we will eventually put in other types of
items
all right but overall
this should work pretty well so let's
let's design oh wait we need a few more
things weapon needs no weapons
but let's have a damage range like a min
and a max so let's just go
we need a damage type uh let's probably
use unsaw indents again we don't want to
do negative damage let's go ahead and go
over to our types
and we've got stat type we could use
stat type but uh
actually stat type well we want to be
unsigned so i think we'll go ahead and
correct that i believe we just didn't
fix that from a later or something at
one point all right but uh let's just
make another new one like that because
this might change uh you went 16
the damage type
all right and it's the same type but now
if we decide that this needs to be
larger we can just go something like
that and it's easy but for now
16 should be good let's save a little
bit of memory all right so there we go
we now have damage type defined and we
can use that
over here in equipment and say we have
damage type
men damage
and damage type max damage
and we do need to set those so maybe
we'll just have it
right here
and
yeah we'll just have like a
damage type men
damage type max and we just need to be
sure to set those let's go ahead and
break this to a new line we got a little
more space there
and we'll just go ahead and set these up
min damage
and
max damage max
and there we go that'll default
construct those
and uh yeah this is the only way to
create a weapon is to use this
constructor so you've got to give it all
this stuff
and that should be good
format key looks good
so there we go now we've got all that
damage ready to go um
all right so let's go over to our main
and we could test out instantiating some
of these but ultimately we want these to
go on to our character now we don't have
an inventory yet so we're just going to
have to equip them right away
and the easiest way to do that is
probably going to be to put it on the
player character delegate and give us
some slots now we haven't we also
haven't worked out the different types
like medium heavy what class could use
what armor and weapons or any of that
stuff or maybe we'll have stat
requirements like you got to have at
least this much strength to be able to
equip this armor kind of like how diablo
does it and uh you know world of
warcraft has class and level
restrictions uh there's a lot of
different ways so we could try to take
inspiration from those and just use
whatever works well for us or come up
with our own system that's somewhat up
to the designer but i think what we're
going to do for now is just sort of
ignore all that and once we actually
start designing more of our real game
and and have some more theory behind how
the armor is going to work and how it's
going to be balanced
and same weapons then we can start
deciding how we want to limit that stuff
or maybe there'll just be none at all
and uh
you know some stuff will just be
obviously you'll have a lot of intellect
on it so it'll obviously be a caster
item you don't want to put that on a
lawyer but we'll have to
decide a little later on that but what
we do need to do is think about how
we're going to do it on
on these guys
now one of the easiest ways to do it is
probably to just put it in this delegate
and have it totaled together when you
get the armor and we'll have some some
ways to equip
so
and then later we could maybe add some
checks if we decide you need to be a
certain class if you if you try to equip
something it's not the right class it'll
just it'll just fail so this is where we
start tying this player character stuff
all together now uh how are we going to
do this that is the big question here
now ultimately the goal here would be to
do this and as little as code as
possible but still come up with
something that works pretty well so i'm
trying to think here the best way to do
that now we do have some things we can
work with and it's basically these slots
so we could essentially assume that
every character has each of these slots
and then we could just make like an
equip uh quick weapon equip armor and uh
see if they've got the slot filled if
they've got the slot filled then it will
you know maybe replace it or something
uh
but if it's empty an empty slot i guess
that's the one we mainly want to work
with right now we don't really want to
start programming and
swapping yet we'll do that later but we
can say if if something is empty you
know we don't have an inventory to pull
to unequip stuff really so we're not
really going to worry about the
unequipped yet which you know it's not
going to be working yet but we're not
done but we can say if that slot is
empty like if you try to equip a helmet
it's going to check if you have one
equipped
and if you don't then it's going to put
it on if you do it's just going to do
nothing probably so we can design that
to begin with that way you can only
start putting stuff on and later we'll
have to worry about
uh you know we have to have an inventory
once we have an inventory that's when we
can start taking stuff off because right
now we're just kind of janking it
together
and that's going to be fine to start and
to get it going so
yeah this is going to be kind of the
hard part so let's just do that let's go
let's go up way to the top here and just
include
our equipment
now we can say if everybody has the
slots we can put the slots in the
delegate but uh we probably want to
well we could also divide the functions
in the delegate so this could just be
already good to go
based on
the player character
but as far as totaling up uh what we've
got we probably need to do that in a
different way
because you can see here uh well
yeah i guess we could design a lot of
that delegate but then we'll have to
have a pc class and the player character
and to equip it to the pc class now if
we want to say just like
maybe all the classes have it anyway
we could just do them directly in here
we could just say like equipment
star and now these could be this is
perfect
for this now we can't instantiate
equipment right
but what we can do is start it out as a
pointer and then if they equip something
we can end up going something like
equipment
equals
new
armor or whatever it is and then give it
all its stats
uh this is actually going to be legal so
random name uh of course that whatever
the stats are we'll just get the default
constructor there uh yep you can do that
oddly enough
now this isn't legal because we're doing
this in a class like we need to put this
in a function or something but i'm just
giving you an example of what the code's
going to look like and armor needs a
slot type here or armor type
and we could say like l
that's
did i spell this wrong i might just
spell this wrong
oh it doesn't have it i don't know why
i'm putting it in there all right
so it'll look something we could do
something like that and then we're just
using some polymorphism to be able to
see what type it is and now when we go
get type id it's going to return
either armor or whatever it is and
that's gonna that's going to work pretty
well or equipment so we'll be able to
check what type we instantiated it as
all right so let's uh let's do some of
this
all right so we're going to try to do
this in as little code as possible we
basically want to do some stuff at
compile time in case the slots change
now it's pretty safe to assume right now
that everybody's got every armor slot
and everybody's got every weapon slot
well the melee might be a little bit
different so we need to we need to have
some other flags here we're going to
change this melee just a little bit
we're just going to have melee by itself
here so either a melee or a range but
there's going to be another flag in here
that we're going to have as
as a stat and it's either going to be
one-hander two-hander or that's that's
pretty much it well
we gotta think about this a little bit
but uh yeah i think we're just gonna
have a boolean flag here or whether it's
a one-hander or a two-hander and that
should be simple enough
uh is to hand
and we'll just default this to false so
they've got to change it to true if it's
a two-hander basically we're not going
to put that
in this uh default constructor or
anything
yeah maybe we will we'll do it in a way
like this uh because the stat might be
ignored for ranged i guess there are
ranged one-handed weapons
uh so that's that that would be a thing
too but for now we're just going to put
is
to hand and we'll just default it to
false that's fine actually you know what
uh forget about that method let's do it
a different way let's do it with a
default value type yes that's that's
going to be easier that way everything
kind of works the same
and we'll just default it to false here
and uh let's see here
boolean i will just put a
almost right out two hit two-handed
right here
and then we can default construct that
and that'll be fine i don't like this
method a lot better it's two-handed and
we'll just put two-handed here there we
go now we got a default value there and
we'll just default it to a one-hander
all right so
these enum classes
now they've got a number and they start
at zero so helmet zero chest is one uh
legs boots etc it goes on
uh i think we're gonna get rid of shield
slot for now it's just going to bring in
too many complications uh overall we'll
make that we'll work with that later if
we need to but basically what we want to
do here is we want to get the number of
armor slots and that's uh you know if
everybody's going to have every slot
that's how many of these equipments
we'll have so we'll go equipment armor
and we'll use an array
but how many are here that's that's the
question so basically we want to make it
armor
slot and
the size so how do we do size well we
know
uh well the way you instantiate this is
well when you type in here say we put 10
that makes slot 0 through nine because
well
that's just the way it works
uh arrays start at zero but when you're
instantiating them
you gotta put the legit number like you
put nine in here it'd give you zero
through eight
that's just the way these arrays work so
we need a way to be able to tell how
many are in here and the easiest way
that i found that will work at compile
time if we change these slots will still
work as we just put a final value here
that says
uh like something like last slot
don't use or something uh we're just
going to call it uh slot number slots
so this is going to be
all of the number of these
and it's the one we won't actually use
this one
so maybe we want to make that clear with
a comment uh num slot for making arrays
of uh arbor
armor slots yeah something like that and
we'll do the same thing down here in
case we add
other stuff later
dumb [ __ ] you can call us whatever you
want people call this last sometimes
sometimes they call it uh well let's see
here i'll bring over this stack overflow
a pretty common thing people do
uh at compile time here and so you can
do a number of items
uh like that or this guy
he does in a kind of weird way that i
didn't like as much i didn't think was
clear
because you have to plus one it and you
have a folders max uh you know either
seems like they would work
but uh
yeah we're just gonna put it
as num slots now we already know it's
armor so there's no need to retype armor
because it's going to be
armor slot uh num number slots
all right so that that should work okay
so here we can now put armor slot
num slots so at compile time it should
make an array
that is the size of the slots
now it's not going to include the last
slot
uh constant has armor slot
instead of the required unsigned long
long so once an unsigned long long okay
well we could do that we can go
unsigned
long long if that's what it wants uh
fair enough we'll change it to that so
this just does a
type conversion there
and uh yeah we know that this is going
to fit in the unsigned long long because
it's only it's only going to be eight
now we can see that this will make an
array of size eight which will be zero
through seven when we iterate through it
so we go back to equipment we can see
that this will be zero one two three
four five six seven there we go
there is no
there is no final slot for the num slots
because of the way it counts zero
through seven so this will actually work
quite good if we try to call an armor
num slots it's gonna fail to equip
because there's there's no slot eight
and same with this hope that makes sense
but that's a little playing around with
the nums and arrays that we're gonna get
to practice with here so that's pretty
cool so we got armor let's make another
one for weapons
all right and this one's going to be of
course weapon
slot num slots so this will make a total
of two
one for melee one for range that's uh
pretty much what we want
and now we need to make so we need to
design some ways to instantiate these
that's going to be the big thing
to do now so essentially we want to
initialize these as zero
all right so we've got some ways of
doing this here
um we're
in like custom managing our pointers
here so we got to be very careful about
what we do here like in our constructor
put on actually let's make a few more
let's delete some of these other
structures we want const
uh player character we want to delete
this one kind of like we did with the
other i don't want people to be able to
copy characters in
oh
and we want to delete the mood
constructor as well and there might be
other ones to delete but we'll cross
that bridge when it comes mainly those
ones and i'm going to move these all the
way to the bottom because we don't
really need to see these ones too often
there we go let's go way down here
move them down here uh good enough just
get them out of our way because we don't
really need to mess with
all right so we definitely have to pass
in a pc class but do we have to pass in
weapon and armor no we don't and the
reason being
is uh you know when you make your
character it's gonna be naked basically
it's gonna have nothing to you quip
stuff so we gotta default all these two
uh
to nothing so for each one of these we
need to
basically default them to null and uh
yeah that should work so we'll just do
some for loops here uh we'll probably
just use auto
and yeah we'll just use
i now we got to do a range loop my i is
less than okay so let's do the armor
first
we'll use this num slots again that's
less than number of slots
then uh we'll continue on the y plus
plus at the end there
and essentially all we're going to do on
this one is just going to make armors
at i
equal null pointer that's just going to
make sure there's no
bad data in there
uh uh we need to set this to zero to
start out
there we go and we'll do the same thing
for the weapon so we'll essentially just
copy this down
call this one weapons call this weapon
slot
we don't walk too far
uh if we can shadow the eye a variable
it's not that big of a deal right here
and might it's not exactly clean code
but it's not going to hurt anything to
shadow these because
uh this is this eye is scoped into this
for loop and this eye is scoped into
this for loop so they're not going to
interfere with each other although
a lot of people will say it's typically
bad practice to shadow variables like
this we use the same one in the same
file or the same scope
or not well we're in the scope of this
player character class but then they
have their own for loop scope so that
you know variables
uh resolve to the scope they're in or
scopes outside of them
another thing we could do is if we we
could just go auto i equals zero up here
and then
we'll just use the same one we don't
declare it here we just set it to zero
to start and then we use it then we go
to the next one we have to do and start
that way we just reuse the same variable
over and over
and that's fine too and then of course
when it exits this it'll it'll destroy
and that might be a tiny bit more
efficient because we're not going to
recreate the same variable but it's it's
such a small minute thing that it
doesn't matter a whole lot but you know
some companies are very particular about
how you do this sort of thing but
ultimately as long as it's clear it
doesn't matter a whole lot as long as it
works correctly and it's clear
but here we're pretty good so now when
we make our new character it's going to
it's going to set all these to null
pointer as intended so we're going to
need to equip but we also got to think
about our destructor here so what if
these have data in them
and our class goes out of scope well
whatever data's in these is going to sit
around but the pointers will destroy so
you don't want that to happen because
the data will essentially leak at that
point as uh the pointer goes out of
scope but we didn't destroy the data
because it you know it's it's managed in
here and we got to manage it properly so
we're basically going to do the same
thing we did with our pc class and just
make sure we delete it now in this case
here with the pc class we're not
checking if it's null or not already
because there's only one constructor and
it's got to be constructed
so it's definitely if there's a player
character class it definitely has this
filled out so we definitely want to
delete it
but in the case of the armor and weapons
they could there could be nothing in
those slots uh in that case it's null so
we essentially want to do the same thing
we'll go back through these loops again
and but this time we'll destroy it
because we'll say if armor's at
whatever this is
uh if it exists so that's just going to
check if it exists this will essentially
be if not null and we'll destroy it
by just uh going like this
armors at i equals well we need to
delete first
delete
oh i think it's belt
and then it says null pointer uh now
let's go ahead and uh put these brackets
in let's auto auto place the last one
but we're gonna need two lines here
because we're also gonna set it to null
pointer just like we do with our
pc class there oh this doesn't work
delete it and then set it to null
pointer and that will clear the memory
out
and we need to do the same thing for
weapons which basically will just take
this
except we'll call it weapons instead of
armor
and it'll go through all of them and
just
delete them but it only deletes them if
they exist if they're already null
pointer if no one ever put anything in
that slot there's nothing to delete so
that that will clean up our class
with this new armor in mind but now what
we need is a way to equip and de-equip
uh
now normally when you de-equip or remove
it's going to go into your inventory we
don't have an inventory so we'll
probably just destroy it at that point
uh yeah that's probably all we're gonna
do is just destroy it if it uh if we
unequip but we'll make it we'll change
it later so that it goes into your
inventory or something more like that so
in here we need some functions to do
that we got a bunch of getters these
getters don't actually do a whole lot
other than you know just get what you
would expect but these all return a copy
so there's no modifications here the
only things i can modify are these here
we probably actually want to
uh
you know say
quite directly what these do so we'll go
modifiers or mutators sometimes they
call these and these are getters
getters and setters
uh
mutators and you know there's different
names here but we essentially just want
to know that hey these are
for getting stuff these ones actually
make changes to the class
uh these are pretty obvious here uh
deleted constructors
that we don't want people to ever use
now we need modifiers to equip and not
equip and maybe we can return a boolean
to be able to tell whether it succeeded
or not because these can actually fail
if they've already got something in that
slot we need to decide what we do they
already got something in the slot do you
want to
well and normally if it's legal
we would uh you know just kind of do us
not not the code swap you know there's a
a word swap that's a keyword but i say
swap in this context i mean like you put
one on and you put the other one in your
inventory we could do that but we'll do
that once we have an inventory for now
we're just gonna uh
do i guess you know we'll just destroy
the old one for now man because what
it's it's not that big of a deal uh
we'll modify that later when we have an
inventory so we'll put a little to do at
the top of this just as a fair warning
uh update once we have an inventory
okay but you know we're pretty bad about
comments in this i'm trying to just talk
about it all but in reality we should
probably be leaving comments on these as
we go especially if you're working with
a team that way if someone goes to
work on this they'll be able to tell you
what you
tell what your intention is now with
comments i will say in general with
comments you don't want to
necessarily say exactly what it does
line by line with your comments what you
generally want is a block
a comic block that
says what the intention is and why
so just keep that in mind intention and
why not not the micro this does this by
every line because that's easier to work
with for some people because they can
get the intention and then see what
you're doing and if they want to rewrite
it and do the same thing in a different
way they can and the comic box stays the
same hope that makes sense but uh that's
that's like the a rule that a lot of
people and companies use that i see
quite frequently all right so we want to
equip uh
yeah i guess we just want a plain old
equip here and this will be able to take
any equip so
if we do it as a pointer
um
we'll be able to tell whether it's an
armor or a weapon so you can just call
this one function for both
and it'll try to equip according so you
call equip you pass it in some equipment
pointer so you'd have to create the
equipment first and then you pass it in
and we also want to think about okay so
now who manages the memory of this
equipment
well this class is so when you equip
something this is going to start
managing the memory of whatever
equipment you're passing in so whoever
had it previously
they would they could just destroy their
pointer because
uh you know for example
if you equip something and someone else
also has the pointer uh they could
delete that uh
they could delete the data that it's
pointing to and then
your your quip was valid but for some
reason you now have this bug where your
equipment gets deleted because somewhere
else in your code someone else had
ownership of it so you gotta you gotta
think about that stuff a lot this is
gonna be some nice practice in that area
but this is also kind of one of the
points of unique pointers
uh in general as well is uh no one else
can control it so it might actually make
sense to just make these
uh slots
unique pointers so no one else can
destroy your items
while they're equipped uh a lot of bugs
like that a lot of games uh where you
know they have dupe problems and it's
it's generally mismanaged pointers
because they're letting something else
still have control over things they
shouldn't have control of so they can
uh they can suddenly get like dupacs and
stuff that way
um yeah so we got to manage this
carefully
is this the point and i think you'll see
that that's this is why you want
computer scientists on your team not
just uh some guy who's a casual coder
because they won't understand stuff like
this and you'll have a lot of bugs so
you're learning some important lessons
here of how to
to manage this memory and just not have
bugs and weird things happen
so hope you're joined
all right this is getting a little
longer than i anticipated but hey we're
getting really close to the end and
we've done some important work uh the
last thing we're gonna do is get this
equip working the best we can all right
so since we're doing something with uh
polymorphism
we can use this particular thing we can
use dynamic cast so here's a here's a
quick setup now this isn't perfect this
is just something that'll work to get us
started and if we want to rework it
later then great all right so we are
going to return a boolean to be able to
tell whether it was successful or not so
if it ends up getting to the end with
false it means it uh failed uh now most
of the time it probably shouldn't fail
but we will have a few fail cases in
here to say it couldn't equip
we should never hit this false because
essentially all right well here's the
thing to use dynamic cast you have to
have in the base class of equipment you
have to have at least one virtual
function if we go look at our equipment
we do have a virtual function right here
so this will work we also probably want
a destructor in here a virtual
destructor we're not going to worry
about that right now we're just going to
kind of skip over that
fine detail
so since we
have a base class
uh that can't be instantiated well yeah
and it has some virtual function we can
use dynamic cast so we can we can
whatever equipment we're taking in here
equipment pointer
like we create armor and then use equip
armor
it will see
can it cast it to armor so if this
works
then it's armor if this doesn't work
it's going to continue on so if this
works in its armor it's going we're
going to equip the armor so here we'll
basically
equip armor and then we'll return true
so it will not execute this bottom part
but if it uh this is false or null
rather if this cast fails then it's
going to skip over this block
and then see if it can cast it to a
weapon pointer and if it can cast to a
weapon pointer then this will be an
actual value
and we know that we can equip it and
we'll do the equip weapon equip
weapon
and return true and if both of these
fail
and it's going to hit this last thing
and just return false so this is a
little system we can use to dynamically
equip things and then to fill this out
we just want to be sure that we fill out
the right slot for these
for our weapons and armor
so well that's all we got to do at this
point really
is just do that and now we had to decide
what are we going to do if they already
have something equipped in that slot and
they put something else there it's dead
well we decide for the moment that we're
just going to destroy the previous item
because we don't have an inventory to
put it into or anything oh sam well we
have this little to do that you know
we'll fix in a later episode we don't
really have time to do all that right
now we just want to get it generally
working so let's go ahead and equip this
uh
let's make this equip armor
so we need to know so a few things we
need to know which slot it's for and
then we just basically need to put it in
that slot uh and that's kind of easy to
do
we'll uh we'll just check the slot so
yeah let's just do that
we'll just go and think about this a bit
here
well we do know that the slot correlates
to the same place in the array
so we'll we first need to check if that
slot is null yeah
second here we might be shadowing
variables here
armors weapons
uh let's rename these a little bit so
i'm going to double r and call this
equipped
armor that way it's just really clear
what these are
hit preview here hit apply
and that's just going to update all
these variable names that we previously
instantiated you can do a find and
replace we need to whatever
whatever you need to do
but uh
yeah i just want to make it really clear
because we're going to be reusing the
name armor and weapon a lot
so we don't want to accidentally call
the wrong one it's just going to make it
really clear
if we go if equipped
armor
and
and then we need to know at what in what
slot and the slot is going to be is
armor
slot and it's going to want this as an
unsigned long long i believe so it's
probably going to be oh i spell it wrong
here
uh or there we go
and it's probably what's an unsigned
long long here so it's going to complain
a little bit so we can just do a cast
let's see what it complains about
operands are mismatched
uh
we just this is just a null check
basically i believe we just got to go
unsign long long here again cast it to
that because that's what it wants for
this array yours might be a little
different on different compilers uh once
again i'm on you know the latest version
of visual studio at this time visual
studio 2022 it's v13 so compare is
needed and i'm just using c plus plus 14
here if you're using something different
or if you're on linux or mac or
something yeah you might get some
different errors and you might have to
cast this to a different type
uh so that's just something to think
about but i'm i'm kind of trying to
design this in a way where it's
cross-platform friendly so if we pull
all this all these files and code over
to linux and make a little build setup
it should compile too that's that's the
goal here but it might not because some
of the stuff that we're using might be a
little a little different so just be
aware of that you might have to do a
little research down below if you find
something else out that's cool that you
think people should know feel free to
leave comments and stuff because people
who read them when they need help
they're stuck on something that i'm
doing that doesn't work for them
and it happens there's no way for me to
cover every single case possible when
coding like this for a tutorial it's
it's just not possible this is too much
uh too many different scenarios
so all right but if this is
so if there's something here
we want to we're just going to delete it
um
yeah so we'll just if it doesn't exist
we'll just equip it
uh so we need an else case here so let's
think about what these do if there's
something already in the slot we need to
get rid of the old data and put the new
one in if there's nothing in the slot
then we just fill it out with this
uh current armor so
uh
yeah here let's go ahead and do this one
uh we'll call delete
and then we'll set it to null pointer
and then
we'll put the new one in
which is gonna be
yeah basically the same thing but now
we're just going to set it equal to this
pointer now you can see we're calling
this
conversion in check a whole lot of times
which is a little redundant basically we
want to do this once and it'd be a
little bit more efficient so we could do
something like this uh well actually
yeah we'll do we'll do an unsigned long
long because that's that's what it seems
to want uh he pulls armor
slot
um and we'll just call this slot num
and of course we got to cast this to the
type at once otherwise it's going to
complain and there we go now we can just
use this slot number over and over
rather than
keep doing the same conversion it's a
little fit you know your compiler might
fix this for you behind the scenes but i
feel like this is maybe a little bit
clearer anyway so can't go too wrong we
need a ending bracket there and there we
go at least we don't have to keep doing
this conversion over and over so we do
have that going for us which is nice
all right so there we go that will take
care of it that will equip the armor and
return true now if we get to this elf's
case it's essentially the same thing we
just don't need to do all these
deletions we'll just go like this and
there we go
that'll just equip it and it's going to
be essentially the same for armor so
let's just take all this stuff and paste
it down here
and clean it up and everything that says
armor is instead going to be a weapon
weapon
uh this will be equipped weapons or
weapon
let's go check what it's called here uh
we do have plural weapons but uh
whatever we'll just go with it for now
we can do a mass rename later if we need
to so let's do the equip weapon case
here
if they already have it filled out we
delete the old one then put the new one
in uh so yeah
we'll put a quick to do here uh
move to inventory
instead of delete
so there we go i'll just put that in
there a little reminder for later uh so
it's kind of clear that uh we're just
doing this temporarily and uh let's make
sure this weapon there we go
so now that's also going to return true
after flipping a weapon so if it returns
true we know the equip was successful
returns false then both these casts fail
and apparently didn't put in a valid
equipment which shouldn't even be
possible at the moment because you can't
instantiate an invalid equipment uh
based on this
this pure virtual function
all right so now that should allow us to
equip stuff so let's let's make a quick
test we got a player character here
and let's go p1 dot whip and we need to
equip an equipment so let's let's give
him some armor
so we're going to create a new armor
here a pointer
called uh
uh we'll call it uh
plate mail let's give them some plate
or maybe we'll call it whatever you want
to call it's fine
and
we're gonna just go equals new to create
it
new armor
and we got to follow this constructor up
give it a name we'll call it a shiny
plate
armor sounds good you can call it
anything you want
and we need some stats so actually let's
let's make the stats ahead of time four
stats
uh
weight armor
stats
and we'll just use the constructor on
that as well well let's see it has a few
different constructors we can use
but essentially none of them allow you
to uh
yeah we've got operators and we could
use a copy one but none of them
have
this stuff lined up so we can't do it
like we do some of the others now we can
put that in there but we're not going to
do that right now let me go back to the
main here
so basically we just have to fill it out
after that because these are all going
to be defaults if we go look at our core
stats here see that they're all going to
be zeros
which is fine we just want to change the
armor and element resistance basically
so we could say that full plate armor
or this plate armor stats
dot armor
equals i don't know we'll say five and
we'll make another line here for element
resistance now this is kind of tricky
because you could you probably want to
have different elements like you would
think plated armor probably doesn't have
any electricity resistance
but uh we're going to kind of ignore
that fact and we'll just say it's got
it's got three because it would stop
like explosions and fire to some extent
but you know it's plate armor heats up
quick we're just that's too much logic
for us to think about right now but
later if we put different element types
we could put that on the stats as well
and different element resistances uh
like they do in diablo and stuff
but for now we're not going to do that
so let's just put this plate armor right
here plate armor stats
and so
next we need a slot now of course
chest slot so armor slot chest
and now we have that item and we want to
equip it so we just go p1 dot equip that
full plate armor and that should do it
now uh what i was talking about earlier
with this pointer
and managing it so what what would
happen here is if you now let's just
introduce an error case all right so if
you go here and then you delete full
plate armor
like so
um
it's gonna it's gonna bug out our
character a little bit because he should
have equipment but something that's not
supposed to control it deleted it uh so
you gotta be careful about that and
there's a case for making this all
unique pointers and stuff because of
that and uh designing the different
system but what we're gonna do is we're
gonna scope this so that after we equip
the armor
it's gonna delete this pointer and
delete these core stats because we don't
need them anymore that's uh
but it's not going to delete the data
when the only the pointer itself is
going out of scope there's data that it
created with new
that doesn't automatically delete unless
that's what it was a unique pointer then
it would automatically delete so you
know there's other ways we can write
this but essentially
putting this in a scope like this will
make sure that nothing happens later to
this data it's just going to equip it
and then
move on now only one person has this
pointer and that's the p1 so p1 has got
to manage it which it does it does
manage it inside its own class it uh
does all the checking when you try to
equip something else
as needed
and if we delete this player character
it uh make sure it gets rid of all this
stuff as well make sure it deletes any
armor
and equipment so that should clean up
after itself properly but we want to
just check now
um because now we can do a few more cool
things and i guess we'll just keep going
with this until it's until it's finished
i know it's kind of long but we don't
want to leave it off we have this
function get total armor and get total
element resistance
and get all these get tolls they should
now include whatever you're getting from
your armor because right now i think
they're just your base stats and your
buffs
but now we also want to include the
armor and we can even say what their
equipment is
so uh yeah that's level up and it we'll
just design some quick set quick little
see out here that's just the level of
buffing of stone shield i don't know
what is this a warrior i don't know if
we wanted stone shield that's fine what
if we'll just leave it i think that was
a cleric thing but now we're warrior so
um yeah
yeah maybe these buffs should be
pointers and we should be doing them
like we're doing this armor as well
so
you know as you go sometimes you come up
with better systems and you want to go
back and redo your old ones and uh yeah
that's kind of what we're running into
but it's good to know the many different
ways and the advantages and
disadvantages of both but let's call
this equipment here
or just arm
in general and we'll just go through all
the armor now we can't we're not using a
vector we're using raw arrays here that
we're managing on our own
so we can't use this auto thing like we
were doing with abilities
although we could you know we could i'm
not going to do this right now but we
could we could say we can make these
vectors of equipment pointers and manage
it that way
but i do want to teach some raw arrays
too they're important to know you don't
see them as much anymore but and you
know if you're coding in c and stuff
that's that's the way to do it you don't
have access to vector vector essentially
does the same thing it just handles
a lot of this behind the scenes that
we're doing very manually alright let's
go back to our main
and let's just spit out this armor but
we essentially want to do the same thing
here for um
we'll just use auto here we'll use i and
start it at zero my i is less than
uh armor slot and we want the num slots
here again
because we essentially want to go
through all the slots and we'll do the
same same thing we'll check if it's null
if
uh
we need the character cp1 dot uh we
don't have any way we don't have any
public function to get the armor those
are all private so maybe we want that
another thing we'd have to design if we
want to
show all the specific names but we could
we could do that we could just do
get armor and then maybe we pass in the
id of which one we want to get
and maybe we could just return a const
pointer
and i don't know if we talked about
const pointers but let's just let's just
design this function yeah because we
want a way to display uh you know armor
and all stats and stuff we're gonna want
that
eventually no matter what so let's go
back to our player character and under
our getters
where's our getters
uh oh this i guess needs to probably
move up here
so there's a bunch of them let's just go
down to the bottom and head down here
and it's going to return
an equipment pointer basically
so well this one will return an armor
pointer we could make it more modular
and return an equipment pointer but
let's just return an armor pointer for
now and it's just going to be get armor
now we want this to be a const pointer a
const pointer will say whoever gets this
pointer is not allowed to modify
whatever it's pointing to they could
still use const cast and cast away the
const and modify it anyway you'll see
plus plus is powerful like that but at
least it being const will not allow them
to do it easily and it will tell them
basically hey this is not designed for
you to change it here basically if you
want to change it you need to use this
quip function and it should be that
simple now oh
i'm i'm gonna skip around back to maine
real quick here because i just realized
quick returns of bull and we just want
to make sure
that this doesn't fail
uh if
if it returns true
it's successful i don't know you know do
we really need that right here not
really uh this is complaining player
character has no member equip oh it's
because we're designing more stuff and
having compiled uh but we could say
let's say here
with success
and we'll maybe make an else case uh for
[Music]
just a quick little notification equip
and since we'll return in the bool we
might as well but when we're designing
our actual game we might use these
differently this is sort of just like a
and just a quick test here
all right let's go back down here and
just kind of keep working on this here
so get armor what's it going to do it's
going to return oh yeah we need to
specify i guess it wants
unsigned long long here we'll put i uh
on the side
because that's what these arrays want
we'll just return equipped
armor
and i
now it's important to note
turn value does not match
uh yeah i guess we want to const cast
this
there
like that
costs cash can only adjust type
quantifiers and not change the
underlying type okay because these are
what
their equipment essentially
so it's gonna it's a little confused
about that so it's not gonna be able to
return
equipment
here
so that's that's something we need to
think about so
we'll have to actually go equipment
right
and let's see if this works
i guess we also have to call this equip
and that works uh i don't know if we
actually need const here it might imply
that automatically so let's just try it
like this yeah that's fine it's gonna
it's gonna apply that automatically yeah
const cast might actually mess things up
but uh yeah read more about const cast
if you're not sure about it but
basically it just changes whether it's
currently const or not it's typically
pretty dangerous and you should avoid it
but in some cases you might need it
okay so this is going to return a const
pointer to equipment and equipment can
be either armor or weapon
so this is just going to return equipped
armor at i so if this is null
this is just going to return a null
pointer and that's fine
because over here we want to be able to
just check that when needed
because this is going to check if it's
null get armor if it returns null then
it's going to do nothing
and then not say anything if it returns
not null we could just say its name
um well we need to uh i guess we need to
cast it to something don't armor
now we'll just call it a pin pointer
here
and
and just you know
i guess it's going to be constant
yeah
we'll just go like this
okay uh
so what's the problem here
uh well we got a warning with this eye
uh not a huge deal i guess it once
unsigned long long
to match this uh armor slot and cast
this well let's just let's just do some
casting we'll just we'll just call this
end let's just keep it simply this is
only temporary code we'll cast this to
an end and then it should be happy
now this one uh we're making a new armor
pointer called temp and we're going to
fill it out with this and cannot be
cannot initialize
so we got to think how do we want to do
this value type of consequence we're not
going to use to initialize entity type
armor
well this uh
is returning equipment
all right so we're doing some dangerous
things here we we want to get armor to
return a constant they can't modify it
essentially but
we could just return
a copy of the data instead
that way
yeah they can sure they can modify it
but it's not going to modify the
underlying one so let's just do this
let's do this instead
we'll say it returns an armor of
equipped armor
uh
i guess we gotta cast this to uh dynamic
cast and do armor
pointer
equipped armor that's just because it's
equipment so
we're not allowed to return it and if we
just put a star here
that should take care of it now why
doesn't it like this
no suitable conversion from armor star
to
armor uh we just need to de-reference it
and that should do it like the
dereference
no it does i think basically we're just
going to need a null check here is one
of the main things but if we just want
to return the copy of the underlying
data i guess we have to maybe design
this in a different way like armor we'll
do a non-pointer version of it all right
so uh but we deleted the default
constructor
so this gets a little tricky to just do
it like this and we have to really think
about what we're doing here
all right so we're just going to go with
this hacky method for now and it seems
to work okay but it's uh
it's a bit dangerous because we don't
have const here so we can
uh dynamic cast to an armor and return
it uh
just like so as an equipment but if we
put constant here
it still seems to be somewhat happy
so let's just try this and let's maybe
try a different few a few different
things and feel free to try some on your
own to to learn but if we're returning
like that that's great well let's let's
just see if we just try to return
equipped
armor at i directly no conversions
anything
that's also happy
uh so if we do it like
like this
then when we get this we need to see we
need to cast it to armor uh like okay so
let's go back to our main and here we
have where we're going through the
different armors and
we go through them
we do a git armor
dynamic cast it to armor and see if it
succeeds and if it does
so if temp is not null then we say the
name
this seems to build
yeah
but will it work correctly and i think
it will let's go ahead and give it a go
there we go armor shiny plate armor
and
this is this is getting a bit dangerous
but at least we've made this const here
so we can't accidentally modify it and
uh
let's just see what happens if we do
this dynamic cast return and hit play
still no errors still the same result so
these work but they're a little
dangerous if we want to make it less
dangerous we need to make that const
right there let's see if that works
no that one fails because cannot use
dynamic cast from const equipment to
armor so it doesn't like it when it's
const because it doesn't allow the
changing of the pointer
but uh
yeah let's try taking const off of that
and see if it does anything different
nope still fails so a little tricky here
a little hacky
but we can get it to work and you just
got to be really careful about this
ideally we do want this to be const
before returning a pointer and we don't
want them to change the data but the
current yeah the current problem with
this is
is it's a getter
and if we wanted to we could say temp
dot
stats dot
armor
equals 10 and we could just straight up
modify the armor but
it's not letting us
because this is const
if we took this const away it now lets
us
uh so we could say here let's just go
with uh
armor
all right we gotta go stats. let's just
save the armor just so we can see uh
name maybe on this uh
so we've got armor we've got name we
know i'm just thinking about formatting
here a little bit let's put a space over
and then
and then say
like
and we'll do the same thing here and
we'll have a name and then it's armor
uh maybe we'll put a dash under here
under that one that way if we get
multiple pieces of armor because this is
going to go through all our armor slots
so let's just test this now we know that
when we created the armor it only had
five
so let's see if it lets it us modify it
through that getter which it should but
it throws an exception
so
why is it throwing an exception here
well
because what's going through this armor
is some sometimes it's going to be null
and we're not allowed to just edit stuff
so we would actually have to do this
after the null check that way and that's
you know some people get confused on
those errors but yeah if you're editing
null pointers it's going to throw a
crash of some sort so we got to do a
null check first basically and there we
go shiny plate armor with 10 so we're
not supposed to modify it so we should
be
just doing const here and then this bugs
out
uh yeah ideally
like i was saying we want this to be
const here but it doesn't seem to like
dynamic cast in that case so
uh maybe we could play around with it if
you know
the
quick answer to make this better feel
free to edit from line 253 here on
github i always check for pull requests
before recording a new episode
uh so you can change it if you want but
for now we're going to stick with this
and we're just going to be really
careful about how we
get the pointer we're going to make it
const right away but let's go ahead and
let's throw him another piece of
equipment here uh just to
show what happens when we have multiple
pieces of equipment and this time
instead of full plate let's just go with
this day
leather helmet weather and we want
different stats here
uh leather we'll default leather helmet
sets
there we go now let's just lower these
maybe it's got one armor one element
resist and put that in here
put this name here to equip and uh it's
going to go out of scope
like before so we can't keep change
things oh this slot is different uh
and this name is different
so
kind of factoring these out
uh leather helmet uh we'll call it plain
give it a little more of a name and uh
first of all let's leave this chest and
see what happens let's just make sure it
overwrites because if you have one
equipped already and you equip another
chest it should delete the previous one
right let's just make sure that doesn't
have an error yeah it looks good looks
like we have a plain leather helm with
negative one armor so something's a
little buggy there it shouldn't have
negative one armor not sure why it did
that uh
oh it's just a dash it's one armor we
just have a dash there so it made it
look like a negative one i guess that's
a little confusing maybe we'll make it
make it this instead all right so i had
one armor that's working correctly
scared me for a second i was like oh so
there we go and maybe maybe we should
just say armor we should just literally
say armor
but we you know we should probably also
say slide this is just uh just to see if
it works and it seems to work fine it is
replacing but now let's go let's change
it to a helmet like it's actually
intended so now we should both have a
chest we should have this full plate
chest and we should have a leather helm
so when we hit play here boom we got
both armor we got plain leather helmet
armor one shiny plate armor two and uh
oh let's check one other thing
the armor on our guy still says zero up
here so last thing i promised on this
episode i know it's been a long one but
it's been a quite an important one i
feel like and that's just the way some
of these are gonna be some are gonna be
quick some are going to be long uh but
we just want to total all that up
so
uh this is called get armor but really
it should be named like
get equipped armor or something get
whipped
armor
and then we'll put at because the app is
uh
this here which they can just pass in a
slot and it'll say it gets the armor at
that slot
and that's that's going to be fine
and we essentially want to do the same
thing for weapons so i'm just going to
copy this paste copy paste this down get
equipped with weapon
and this one we're going to cast to a
weapon
and call it equipped weapons but it
essentially works the same
uh you just uh you they won't be able to
this will fail to cast
to armor so they can't like you can't
mess these up or you're going to get
compiler errors basically is going to be
the point here but now we do have a get
total armor which calls pc class get
total armor and that's it's going to get
your base armor and stuff from the buff
so the buffs are tied to a dc class
because they're there's a vector of them
in the player character delegate up at
the top but the armor
we're we're doing that all in this
player character down here so we
actually need to hold the total that up
a little bit differently
which we can do
uh so we do want this armor from all
their class stuff maybe they've got i
don't know some special class ability
that gives them more
but we just need to total up all the
armor and we can do that by going
through a loop just like one of these
i go through all their armor slot loops
uh weapons could
in theory have some armor on too but
we're gonna pretend that they don't
uh so i get all armor
from equipped arm let's do that first
um and we're just going to total it up
and a
stat type
stat type
armor from armor
that's a variable name doesn't it and
we're going to start it out at 0 of
course
and we just need to total these up this
this here should be fine uh we need to
have this
actually be it type oh just going to
leave it auto is fine and check equipped
armor no we're not going to delete this
time
if it's not null then we plus it
together
plus equals
uh whatever one we're at
with armor that slot so if it's not null
we just keep adding to it
dot
stats right there well i guess it's a
pointer so it's dot stats dot arm
there we go and that should just total
up all the armor and we need to just add
it at the end here armor for one
there we go so that'll just total up all
the armor of everything you have
equipped and return it all once along
with the pc classes armor
uh from their buffs and stuff and there
we go now get total armor
should work correctly and you're
probably starting to see the point of
this player character class a little
more uh so
if we go and this is kind of weird
because okay here's our level two
warrior let's just look at this
highlighted area only uh their total
armor is six
because they're getting well one from
the leather and five from the plate so
that seems correct
and currently their class doesn't give
them any bonus but if it did it would
also be in there
so uh yeah that's it you can you can see
how to basically extrapolate
all this
for the element resistance which we
technically need to do except instead of
armor from armor it's going to be resist
from armor so we'll just rename this
to resist
from
and uh total this up
and element versus t here but we
essentially do this for all the stats
now we would want to get
uh
all the stats uh for like uh
well the base is going to stay the same
but the totals now we also want to
get all of it from all our equipment as
well and you can imagine how to do that
it's just basically these same loops and
the same thing
except we'd be sure to get the right
stat and
return it with it all totaled together
like that so
uh i'm sure you can imagine
and
why don't you just do that as a practice
if you're following along
just do this for all these with strength
intellect and agility as well and i will
include in the code but i'm not going to
include it in the episode because it's
at this point kind of redundant for me
to do that same thing over and over
let's go back to our main one more time
and uh
yeah i don't know
these stats
uh break into a new line is yeah it's
kind of whatever at this point
but there we go we have name
uh maybe we'll just put in like
parentheses here we'll just do like a
little thing like a
for armor there just to kind of put it
all in one line it's a little formatting
stuff not not something you really need
to do
but uh
we could do this well what if we don't
want a new line here we just want an r
and then we'll say the resistance that
you're getting from it too so you can
just kind of see the stats from it
basically
and then a new line and we'll see what
that looks like
all right so now this should total it
better let's look at the level two
there he is at level two and we can see
he's got armor or these two and it shows
their stats with an a and an r uh we've
got a space here we don't need it in
parentheses but you can format that
however you like and really it's still
temp code in the long run we want to
have a graphical interface but we
probably still do want to get these uh
the string data to put in our graphical
interface to display text in a graphical
format this whole console thing i know
i've said it a million times but just
want to reiterate that it's literally
just for testing at this time it's not
something we plan on using in the very
end unless well i guess it's up to the
end user if you just want to have a text
only rpg hey that's a thing apparently
those you know those do fine and some
people like those they might be fun to
play in some cases but as you can see
it's essentially doing what it's
supposed to do we got the resists we got
armor
the resist is nine why so much resist oh
i guess we're getting some from our
level up because resist is four at level
one uh resist is
nine at level two and that's probably
from stone shield
i think because we got uh level two
let's just look at this real quick
uh back into maine where's maine here we
go a big test case here
yeah we make our warrior we equip a few
things
and then we show all the stats basically
in all his abilities now one of the
abilities to get we could have down here
that we're leveling up on level two
because this you know goes through this
twice uh
this armor buff
so if we go look at this buff what we
got we got a name and then a ten zero
zero zero five uh what is this so we can
look at this and see what it's doing uh
based on how these buffs are designed so
name oh it's giving us a bunch of
strength which we don't intend we
actually changed how this works a little
bit
uh element resists strength intellect
agility armor element resistance so
actually
this should be a little bit different
now
but
you probably get the point so you gotta
you gotta be careful about how you're
designing those and design buffs as
they're actually intended all right so
let's go back to the main let's just
change the stone shield to make it
actually give you armor
because that makes sense uh let's call
it uh thick skin
warriors are tough they have some thick
skin and let's see this was strength
intellect agility let's give them a
little bit of armor here let's give them
three armor three all right let's just
do two two arm or two magic for this so
we'll say warriors at level two get this
thick skin ability just just because
it's just an example for now and we just
want to see that it actually
works and populates so
six and four based on the armor and
plate there
or the leather and plate and then they
go up by two thanks to
the abilities insane power attack why
does it say power attack uh
uh
oh yeah
well we're not saying the buffs anywhere
this is this is a buff but if we look at
our player character
yeah we have the warrior designed in a
way let's find a warrior here
we have the warrior designed in a way
where when he levels up the two he gets
power attack
uh so that's a permanent ability he gets
but the buff is temporary now of course
we still need to work on those buffs to
give them a duration and we'll do that
once we start doing combat and there's
actual rounds ticking then we'll have
buffs wear off when they're supposed to
wear off all right i hope you've enjoyed
the episode hope you've learned a lot
especially about pointers this has
probably been incredibly valuable
valuable about pointers if you don't
know about them hopefully you know a lot
more and understand a lot more and i'll
see in the next episode peace out guys
[Music]
you